[Music]
in future dating news
oh no candor in the future one more day
when I'm dating thinks these gonna pass
away where does this weird a shape she's
gonna go man I don't like it I was just
trying to use this to make you so far
you're denying bits that I do are you
rejecting bits outright
she's a bumpkin didn't happen in this
video now everyone's confused now you're
saying you're gonna divorce me or
whatever she's a ballbuster I was
talking about the video that where I
called you out in any way this is what
you've been learning at UCB it's not
cruising down the street
mi6 fault so yes and right there you see
that you should have been like cruising
down the street well a about Nikki's
like know who said that you're gonna
make her cry what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
see do you want to have a bad day he's
already crying I don't know why you're
so special evening socks already crying
we're still together I'm just dating
that's all but not leaving you there's a
new heart there's a new school in town
called ECU and then the game is no and
everything's opposite a Japanese
speed-dating event requires no talking
at all
just [ __ ] kidding they still go like
this Japanese people are weird
there's an iPad screen in between not
talking just [ __ ] thank you is it
like that video where that girls in the
middle and she's texting everyone in a
circle is it like then kind of yes sorry
so this speed-dating event had these
tiny little robots talking to each other
while the people are just sitting there
oh that's like black mirror tips like
that's so cute it's a little thing to do
but I think this be like really
disturbing okay like they should be
talking to each other but I guess
because they're so shy or whatever it is
so before they go before they had this
event there was this 45 questions survey
that participants filled out prior to
the event and so these tiny little
robots have the answers to the questions
in that survey so pretty much these
robots are hyping up the person
while they're like sitting there but
they're not even looking at each other
either they're looking at the robot so
the people had said that they they've
liked how they panned out because they
didn't feel like weird because like
we're answering questions about
themselves without them feeling like
they're not selling themselves or like
they're being too cocky
so is it like this like there's a robot
to show you a video okay like Rock'em
Sock'em robots something before I showed
this but you're too confused yeah you
got to show the video first what your
hobbies what she says what's your
hobbies or some [ __ ] also the robots
they're already pre-programmed with the
questions and they're having the
conversation nothing would have had you
have they get to witness the robots
hiding in conversation yes there's other
humans that they could converse with
there's that the part that I find really
weird and they're missing like 80% of
communication a body language and the
way that people express them seconds
voice that's so here's like speed dating
every interaction lasted about three
minutes and so at the end of that
interaction participants would decide
whether they wanted to engage in direct
conversation with the person or not and
then so they're saying that four couples
came out of this event out of lemony
that's good they need to stop talking
men and women oh that's really good
that's pretty pretty good rapport that's
really good even the Germans give them
money to like pop out babies but they're
like no yes so they're saying here like
in Japanese society humility is always
considered a virtue and so people are
always conscious about the fact that
that like they don't want to come off as
like braggadocious exactly braggadocious
and so that might be seen as dull by
others and so that's why a lot of people
were just really reluctant to self
promote themselves so then that's why
having this robotic wingman was a great
help
oh that's interesting what if they had
the robots talk Wow one guy jacks off
another girl just finger-banging herself
so the conversation
you still go on okay but they could stop
some sort of physical intimacy so far
it's a business I don't see what I don't
see what else to do with it though
you just described up a really good
business yeah but now I'm trying to
trying to figure where it goes from
there so if they like the conversation
while they're physically pleasuring
themselves yeah then they can take it to
the second date
I see yeah I'm sure myself I'm already
thinking of someone else anyway no but
you're listening to the yeah pay
attention oh you're getting up on the
robot voice you're here you're hearing
how well you guys actually get along so
imagine this thinks that that those
things turn women on no no what's your
favorite movie okay so imagine like a
little about what movie do you like and
in the guy robots like oh I'm like
Amelie and then the robot oh me too
while your finger banners up while I'm
jacking off is like oh [ __ ] there's like
something odd going on here
that's just distracting I want to think
about someone like a gang banging me
like that so thinking about Amelie now
I'm thinking about Amelie and all the
things they're doing and all that that's
a question 43 so the questions get
crazier and crazier so the question for
three is like do you like game baby but
then for you you can Jack yourself off
and finish twenty eight times no the
twenty eight contestants I don't have
the Japanese discipline they can do
normally they all orgasm and maybe
that's why I thought yeah I'm sure great
stuff I think this is a good way for the
people that are stuck in their rooms all
day that don't know how to go out and
then start meeting people that's what I
was thinking it must be cultural cuz
when she was saying like that there it's
hard for them to self promote themselves
than that that makes sense it's almost
like a dream form of humility this is
like this is like probably people that
are just try something different or they
themselves this isn't it's just so
[ __ ] creepy I just I'm always creeped
out by all this stuff especially robots
stuff it just is very creepy to think
that this point people are so desperate
to find love that they're like [ __ ] it
I'll do the robot thing let's just do it
let's just find out because I know my
single friends that are still single
they're like freaking out they're like
I'm 30 I'm still single and they're like
just on every single 10
in every dating after like I just need
something and they're American they're
not even in Japan which is even a more
closed off society right right I think
the phenomenon of people dating later
and marrying earth later and not even
having kids and all that that's
happening all throughout developed
nations but next our nature balancing
itself though because we like
overpopulate like crazy and then now
it's like I also think it's the how
difficult it is to have a family you
need it's almost like you're choosing
between freedom and all this dance
careers it logically doesn't make sense
like before in the 50s the dude just
worked and the mom could say hominy you
could support the whole family and buy a
house and do all this stuff now it's
like both parties have to work and it's
better barely making ends meet and
living wages are really hard to come by
yeah cuz that's one of the biggest
reasons why Japanese youngsters aren't
marrying like they're still [ __ ]
they're still having fun that's they're
still yeah but they're not marrying
they're not having kids because they
like the freedom and if you do get
married and all these things like it's
Tokyo is a more expensive city than LA
is it's taking a longer time for people
to start their lives because of all the
student debt and stuff so people are
living with their parents longer like
throughout their 20s instead of you know
moving out and that's dropping birth
rates just by living with your parents
yep
people don't move out in Japan either so
they have loved hotels and stuff where
they could just hook up well it's pretty
culturally normal to once you you know
become an adult and then you get married
your wife comes to the family home or
you just upgrade the house with your
whole entire family and you move
together yeah well you know people could
not live with our my in-laws or
yeah my folks and it's not small or
whatever too so it's it's difficult but
that's ID it's culturing normal - of
what do you call it vital vital poop
guilty or some [ __ ] like that well
you're like it's like a I forgot the
name but it's like a it's like your
parents and you there it's it's this
whole relationship it's very different
and it's a it's more of a unit like a
family unit right so like once your
daughter gets married she goes into that
other family and
at that home that's how it used to be
before a nuclear family so everyone
feels so that's how they maintain the
wealth and build wealth within the front
it actually makes sense because what
would happen was the grandparents would
watch the kids and the parents could
live like have their life and stuff and
then that's how it always but that's how
it worked because they were right there
with you to watch the kids the elders
like watch and it's almost kind of
messed up to put your grandparents in a
hole yeah you have like a medical
condition or whatever like they
typically like once you become an adult
your parents live with you and then you
now start taking care of them yeah but
what if they fall like if they fall one
time they're basically they're gonna
[ __ ] be in a hospital bed for six
months yeah I mean that's the logical
thing to to when you're thinking logical
yeah but then I think they're stuck to a
certain mindset and how to do things
yeah yeah it sucks right when you become
an adult you have to get married now you
start taking care of your parents and
you have to take care of your kids and
you're just working it's not sexy
anymore
it's boring yeah it's like why do I have
to take care of all this [ __ ] and the
same thing is happening all over the
world where the whole like retirement
baby boomer yeah
there's less workers now that have to
give more money to the retiring or the
aging population dang it would suck to
advocate right now so I don't have a kid
right now you know you gotta have money
bucket op you gotta have a lot of money
yeah did you keep the receipt oh this is
a very one-sided conversation I think
it's been more than 90 days kids are bad
they're culturally bad so then people
don't want to [ __ ] they're like well I'm
like I don't want to deal with some
other dude I can still [ __ ] I walked
out kids that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]